i expect the first shipments to arrive  monday morning extensive coordination  will ensure that this occurs we have  worked with pfizer  mckesson ups fedex  federal and local law enforcement  agencies to ensure  safety and security of the vaccine  make no mistake distribution has begun  right now boxes are being packed and  loaded with vaccine  with emphasis on quality control within  the next 24 hours  they will begin moving vaccine from the  pfizer manufacturing facility  to the ups and fedex hubs and then it  will go out to the 636 locations  nationwide which were identified by the  states  and the territories we expect 145 sites  across all the states to receive vaccine  on monday another 425  sites on tuesday and the final 66 sites  on wednesday which will complete the  initial delivery  of the pfizer orders for vaccine